- Do not drink the
airplane bathroom water.
(funky upbeat music)
- Do people attempt to
join the Mile High Club?
Yes, it is a big fantasy for everyone.
Everyone tries to give
you a little tip money.
- Pretty sure I had passengers
give each other hand jobs
right in front of me.
So what did I do?
Well, offer 'em a warm towel.
(laughs)
- If you get caught doing
it, it's a big deal.
It's a federal offense.
- You get arrested, and you will be fined.
You will be banned from the airline, and
no more flying for you to Mexico.
Do flight attendants
talk about passengers?
Yes, all the time.
Oh my gosh.
That's the first thing out of our mouth.
- We always know what's
going on with our passengers.
From the moment they step on that plane,
there should be a greeter
up at the front saying,
welcome aboard, and at that moment we know
if we've got, you know,
a newlywed couple going
on their honeymoon, or somebody
who's a first time flyer
who says, I'm nervous,
I'm a first time flyer.
Most of the time, they'll
tell us, or they'll give us
some type of cue.
- First of all, when you're
boarding, we're always
checking you out, seeing
who's the sexy one,
and then we rate, and like
okay, who's the hottest guy
in coach; or girl.
Who's the hottest guy,
or girl in first class.
And then who's the hottest
person in the whole plane.
So if you see us in the
back talking and giggling
and looking at the
passengers, that's most likely
because I'm talking about you.
What is potable water?
How is it used on a plane?
- It's the water we
use for the lavatories,
and for the coffee.
The same water.
I'll leave that up to you if
you wanna drink your coffee.
- I wouldn't drink the coffee on a plane.
They don't clean the tubes
where the water goes.
So you're drinking all of that.
So if you want water, get
it from the bottled water.
- What is the dirtiest
part of an airplane?
Definitely the floor.
The floor gets used and abused.
People are walking all around that floor,
bringing stuff in, taking
stuff off, dropping things.
- Do not walk barefoot on that airplane.
Especially going to the lavatory.
- Everyone's always
walking around barefoot,
and getting like, fungus or something.
- I see people walk in
barefoot in the lavatory
and I'm like, oh, that's
a lot of confidence.
- Bring your own Chlorox wipes.
No guarantee if those tray tables or seats
get cleaned after every flight.
- In between flights, they
do clean, but what they mean
by cleaning is they vacuum
the carpet and, they do
wipe down the lavatories,
but every single tray table,
no, they don't wipe that down.
They only do that only if
the plane is like, sitting
in the airport for like,
overnight or something.
- How can a passenger
get into first class?
Well, they can buy a ticket.
- Upgrade your life.
(laughs)
Work harder.
You gotta buy a ticket, man.
There's just no way.
- Or, they can ask a flight attendant.
Never hurts to ask.
If they can talk their
way into it, some of them,
and they ask nicely, they
can get into first class.
I've seen it done before.
- We're not supposed to,
but if you're really cute,
we just say, hey, come over.
I'd rather have you over here.
- If you guys are gonna
be asking, you ask before
the plane takes off.
- If you wanna get anything
free on an airplane,
it's actually pretty easy.
Just be super nice to
your flight attendants.
If you're having like, a
drink or two, I've met a lot
of flight attendants
that would just be like,
oh, I'll come back and charge you later,
and they never come back.
- Are diet drinks the worst
drinks to order on a flight?
Diet cola is literally the
worst drink to pour on a flight.
The bubbles, for some
reason, they never go down.
They're so fizzy.
So we'll open the can,
and pour it, and we'll
literally just wait.
- That fizz takes so long
to de-fizz that I coulda
poured a whole plane drinks by the time
that Diet Coke de-fizzes.
If you order a Diet Coke
with me, you'll probably
get the whole can, 'cause I
don't got time for all that.
- Well, thanks for watching.
Hopefully you learned some
important, helpful tips
for your next flight.
Be nice to your flight
attendant, and b'bye.
- Have a good day.
- Good bye.
(upbeat music)
- So be nice to your flight
attendants, just like
you would be nice to your
waitresses and puppy dogs.
We're just there for your safety, dang it.